well it's official the Xbox 1s all
digital edition is coming and it's
making a lot of people ask themselves
whether the future of gaming is indeed
digital and what we'd be missing out on
if we abandoned disks putting aside the
fact that some clever users have pointed
out that the acronym of the new console
spells out Xbox one sad Edition which is
very funny
let's take into whether or not this is
the box we're looking for so at a basic
level what are they offering Eddie this
is a xbox one S without a disk drive
it'll cost $250 in the United States
comes with a one terabyte hard drive and
it comes with three games right out of
the box including Minecraft sea of
thieves and Forza horizon 3 it's fifty
dollars less than you know the retail
price for an xbox one s but I think a
lot of people thought this was going to
come in at you know 200 yeah and in
terms of the hard drive you know one
terabyte is that is quite a large hard
drive but you know with the way games
are getting bigger and bigger in terms
of their file size you know 50 gigs or
more is probably pretty much the
standard for a you know triple-a game
and you know you look at Halo the Master
Chief collection that's one of
Microsoft's
you know marquee first party titles
that's more than 70 gigs so you know
that one terabyte in addition to the
software space that consoles gonna
require to begin with you know it's
gonna fill up really really quickly
right so let's talk about the price I
think is really interesting obviously it
makes sense for gamers who largely use
digital to save a few dollars and not
get a dry they weren't using in the
first place it seems like a no-brainer
but I guess the other thing that's worth
considering is you won't have the option
anymore so say like a mate buys a $60
game you can in it and then it's on a
disc you can no longer borrow it you
know you won't have that option to trade
in old games for new ones
once you if you were into buying like a
full priced game you won't then be able
to on sell it maybe make some of that
money back all of those things will be
like out of the realm of possibility
so I think that's worth considering and
why I think people were expecting to
make me get a few more dollars off yeah
I mean I there are definitely drawbacks
but when you consider like games are you
know trending more digital every year
and Microsoft specifically and they're
actually being a leader in this category
now with this they are the first major
platform besides the PSP go years ago
to offer a you know a consult without a
disk drive and you know digital is all
about convenience and you know Microsoft
has game pass so right there in one
package you have more than 100 games for
you know one monthly price and you know
that ties into their other big
announcement today it was there finally
bundling Xbox Live Gold and game past
together for $15 a month which you know
saves you a bit it's not a massive
savings considering Xbox Live Gold is
typically on sale but it is a savings
you know all the same and a game pass
just continues to grow and value it's
probably one of my favorite subscription
services out there right now there's new
games added every month and it'll be
really interesting to see what they do
in the future with that considering they
also have their cloud streaming platform
coming up which is also 100% digital so
it'll be really interesting to follow
how this all plays out sure and if
you're already a consumer who really
focuses on digital and doesn't mind too
much about the retail or a hardware
aspect and you are saving $50 on your
console and then $5 on your monthly
subscription to getting this game cause
especially if that's something you're
already doing that doesn't definitely
make it seem like a better value
proposition absolutely and I think the
other thing to consider here and really
stress is that this is like Microsoft is
not saying digital is the only way
forward we're never gonna make this your
disc based life there's no longer
supported this is one console out of
there a variety of you know offerings
including the traditional Xbox one is
the Xbox one X there's rumors that at e3
they're gonna announce a couple more
consoles remains to be seen if those
will have drives but you would imagine
they would so this is merely Microsoft
doing what they typically say is you
know just giving people options
this would be a option if you want this
and in that way it's very exciting to
see a company as big as Microsoft doing
something you know as trailblazing is
this I think the other issue that people
are talking about is just that idea of
ownership its ownership versus what is
essentially like a license to a game the
same way that we need stream things on
Netflix you don't own that DVD copy you
don't own that blu-ray to like put on
your shelf that's actually yours you own
it for as long as you have that service
as long as you have whether it's Xbox
Live or if it's game pass or whatever
else and how important that is to people
yes I completely agree like it is very
important to a number of people I just
think at the
the day another thing is that just like
convenience the convenience factor if
you want something you want it right
away
this will be a way to do that it's
something that's happening a lot in the
PC space where PC game is of building
their pcs with no optical drive because
it's just not a consideration anymore if
they're buying exclusively digital and
it's just like not something that's
required yeah and but kind of when you
look at the other side of that I think
another thing to consider is that
internet speed and availability is not
the same around the world there are
places where it's this kind of console
would probably just not be feasible and
you know you have to think that
Microsoft knows that and this kind of
feels like a test for the future to see
where this digital future could go and
it's really I mean I see this as only a
positive this is one option I'm amongst
a suite of Xbox one consoles that you
can buy yeah so let us know down in the
comments section if this sounds like
something that'll work for you are you
happy with the trade-offs are you happy
with the price point do let us know all
of your thoughts for everything else
that's come out of today's a Microsoft
live stream do check back to GameSpot
and we'll see you again soon
[Music]
you